do you remember the film Honey I Shrunk
the Kids it's a classic tale about a
wacky scientist that accidentally
shrinks his own children and they end up
going on this Whimsical Adventure sounds
fun right no the truth is in real life
it would be super dangerous everyone
would die brutally and we're going to
prove it for this next generation of
kids to make sure
this doesn't happen to them by making
Honey I Shrunk the
Kids
[Music]
so how do we make this beloved
children's film rated R truly well it's
going to take the power of editing and a
ton of visual effects yesterday we
gathered some of the best VFX artists in
the office to look at clips of Honey I
Shrunk the Kids and kind of see if we
can recontextualize them with VFX some
of the guys had some really good ideas
but now comes the really tricky part for
me I have to take those scenes and put
it into a bigger narrative these can't
just be random scenes of violence with
tiny children we need actual Stakes we
need a story so I've taken Rick Moranis
Wayne zalinsky and I have made him a mad
scientist a man that has truly one goal
and that is to murder his entire family
so I found a lot of really funny like
little moments in the movie and lines of
dialogue that can really help like build
our narrative but when that's all said
and done we still have like one major
question to answer and that is what is
this trailer what kind of world are we
building here well this kind of gives me
an excuse to do something that I've
wanted to do at Corridor forever and
that is to make a Grindhouse 80s
throwback film before I started working
here I loved playing in that like
schlocky horror kind of vibe and I would
do it a lot in my films so this is where
I get a chance to actually do it so in
order to capture this 8s Grindhouse vibe
in a trailer I'm going to need to head
head on over to epidemicsound.com which
is the sponsor for today's video it's an
incredible and Powerful tool for
filmmakers they have this huge Library
sound effects and music one thing that
really helped my search for the 8S
horror Vibe was the F similar tool just
see what other tracks they have in the
same mood genre Vibe you can split the
stems of every single track I can pull
from the bass the drums the instruments
the melody to pick the exact kind of
tone I'm going for in this trailer they
also have different licenses for all
types of production so sign up using the
link in the description to receive a
free 30-day trial thank you epidemic
sound
[Music]
cheers I think everything is working in
this piece right now we have the music
we have the tone that Grindhouse feel
and I love that but what we need now is
we need VFX artists to start VFX in
there's one thing in this piece sort of
a through line uh there are an
incredible amount of exploding bodies
and decapitations what I believe we need
is a secret weapon we need a Peter
France Peter my boy hey so we're doing
this uh this new R rated for Honey I
Shrunk the Kids you are kind of the best
in the business in terms of blowing up
heads and bodies I would love to help
you but we have a problem here I've been
working on this virtual reality game for
the last year and I haven't done an
effect shot in months I'm scared I don't
have it anymore Peter I I know you doubt
yourself
right now but I know you can make a
great body explosion and I know that you
can do this Peter so believe in yourself
make it happen thanks man yeah that's I
really need to hear that I'm going to
get started that's right go for it go
for it buddy is he just he's just going
to he's walking away I'm still on the
line Peter I'm still on
the my experience as an intern um it's
been great honestly like everyone's so
welcoming encouraging feel like perhaps
you have big shoes to fill as the intern
big shoes probably Peter like Peter he
he inspired me to get into blender and
like the first place to be honest like
him in Hubert all those like big blender
names I guess but yeah like all of his
tutorials Spider-Man all those tutorials
yeah those are like the big
ones oh my god I've been here the whole
time sitting at this desk they just
haven't been filming me I didn't get
fired I haven't been working on a VR
game I've been here I think the secret
to a good head explosion is layering so
we start with our skin I cut a bunch of
little pieces into the head there and
then simulate those little skin flaps
just flying out slapping all around and
then you add a little bit of thickness
to that skin and put a layer of just red
gross yucky flesh behind it we're just
here to show the dangers of shrinking
but what's under the skin really
emotionally and physically you got to
have musculature in there you got to
have a skull in there some teeth a
tongue put them in the face added a
little bit of simulation flapping on the
the muscles just to add some nice
movement whatever but a lot of that is
going to be covered up by the hair and
the blood simulation the final thing I
did was right when the head explodes you
just add a bunch of particles of Flesh
and Blood and all that nastiness just
flying in every direction head explosion
I hope he likes it I want to make him
happy honestly Peter I think you still
have it you came out of retirement and
You Came Out Swinging and zapping and
exploding thanks Dad and it works it
works Budd appreciate that it freaking
works that means a lot to me yep
also I like the dad thing maybe I'll
yeah you prefer dad daddy Papa
poy poppy
puy look there's two shots right at the
beginning of this piece that when I saw
them I knew I'd have to tackle them
there's a funny shot where the neighbor
is yelling through his window and we're
like oh let's pretend like he shoots his
neighbor with the laser I think we can
do more than that though the first thing
I'd have to do camera match this scene
we have our geometry and we have a
generic mixim guy I was thinking you
know what let let's just see if I can
add a whole cloth simulation to
everything I have that going on right in
the center of the character but I also
have an emitter that's emitting physics
objects just balls boom and these balls
are also shooting through the cloth
simulation it's horrific then to like
amp it up here I got some balls and
particles emitting basically smoke but
the second half is where it really gets
fun there's a big ball behind this house
why is that well I've taken this wall
where the windows are and I've actually
fractured all of it as well so that way
when the explosion goes off the house
itself will get damaged Kaboom kaboy
very violent you can see those streamers
working their magic there but I'm not
too happy with like the colors of the
explosion I know when you're shooting
fire it just looks nice when you give it
that rich hot core it's a Cheesy 8s
laser so I'm going to use a cheesy 80s
plugin for it the whole point of these
red our videos is to really have fun
reworking this footage and seeing like
what's the most you can do it's a really
great
challenge my shot I've been dedicated
one kid to kill the blonde boy with the
cap I believe was his character name
whatever the kids what's the kid's name
uh Jimbo Bing Bong Jimbo Bing Bong I
think that's a weird stage name Bing
Bong I don't know why there's not
already a 3D model of this kid right
there Isn't So I have to make him from
scratch Sam helped me out here drafting
something up in 15 minutes in character
creator there's just one massive problem
with this kid and it's that he has a
head he manages to somehow avoid the
snap of a scorpion's claw this is not
true to life and so what we want to do
is we want to make sure that he gets
nicked just a little off the top and we
do that literally with a Boolean cut I
take a plane and I just sliced right
through the head I went ahead and added
a neck bone it's basically a picture of
steak with a bone in the middle once he
has all these things we plug it into the
rag doll suver adding physics to it and
this gave us this effect and it looks
pretty good but the cloth the cloth is
static and boring and is morphing with
his body which is not what cloth does if
I get flung forward my shirt you're
going to see the ripples in it right
look at that
this is what we don't want or this is
exactly what we want so that's what we
did um I stripped the boy oh gosh and
then run another simulation cloth
simulation so this already feels so much
better it's like the difference is
tremendous a freshly cut stump I think
it's going to bleed a little bit what I
did is I isolated the top of the neck
there that little meat plate ran a
liquid simulation through that so we've
got it we've done it is this do you have
a fin show here
actually yes look at him oh he's so
headless from the moment he gets
beheaded I think it should just be
gurgling you know what we could do today
Jordan Allen we could record some
vo ladies and gentlemen it is time for
everybody's favorite segment where we
scream into microphones for minutes on
end why are you guys eating just very
unprofessional just shoving your faces
with check mix all right so you're
getting shrunk as you can see right
[Music]
here just like how you would as like
just you human TR more human girl human
girl more human being
girl yeah good great that's good all
right Jordan Coleman you're done here
watching time for the
[Music]
men daddy daddy don't yeah Dy
don't
all right I'm over it let's we're
wrapping I'm
exhausted the visual effects are done
the sound design is designed but there's
that extra little bit of sauce that we
need to really immerse this in the80s
here's how I'm going to do that overall
we need to think about how a 8s film is
made they're physically cutting film
that can lead to some Jank especially if
it's low budget that's why we're making
some choices like this freeze frame of
the ant that just everything just just
turns red cuz red is the color of bad so
another thing about the80s they're
transferring their titles onto film with
that comes Jitter it's the wiggle effect
man you you wiggle it up if you get the
wiggle you get the Jiggles then you're
definitely winning with the titles they
did have some digital Graphics you were
flexing that stuff immediately so at the
very top of this trailer I have an old
school looking Corridor Digital
logo another key ingredient is the
narrator voice they have a very specific
sound an alien Creature if it had a
heart you could kill it no one believed
it so I got the perfect actor his name
is Don Lampkin to do this voice so you
got yourself a trailer that feels
authentically 80s except for one thing
the VHS effect I'm not just going to
slap a filter digitally I want to go a
little more analog and this is how we're
going to do that I've transferred the
whole trailer onto this VHS tape to give
it that authentic 80s grunge and now all
we have left to do is Show The Crew and
see what they think
wow look at this collection of friends
like you I watched this movie as a child
and I dreamed of being shrunk down ride
ants like horses fly on little beetles
that sounds terrifying yeah it is it is
actually terrifying and so that's why
we've reimagined this say no to underage
shrinking oh I get the joke
[Laughter]
[Music]
now in this quiet Suburban Town
something sinister is stirring one mad
scientist toils away it is mechanical
Abomination not again who does he think
he is zinski give it a rest it's
Saturday now he has one last bug to
squash when's mom coming home mom and
dad had an argument last night don't say
the n-word around 2-year-old
oh his
family I have a surprise typing with his
gloves on again
[Music]
Dad the machine had blown up the kids
there'd be pieces of them
everywhere they're in the backyard he'll
stop at nothing to finish the
job but
sometimes tiny
things come in deadly
packages hang on
K guys come on great idea R you report
of missing children are in the
[Music]
backyard
laow Honey I Shrunk the
Kids what makes it so good is the hair
hair on the skin flaps you got these
like triple level physics Sims going on
the flaps flapping and the hair's
flapping on the flap and it's like woo
the layers I knew that it was a Peter
special and so I don't think he's Rusty
at all so thanks Jordan it it it looks
you know just like all your other brutal
ones a moment of silence because Sam
made a visual effect shot where the
neighbor exploded and he didn't just
explode from the laser he was like it
was like a nuclear bomb it went off and
it was entirely too
much I genuinely love the idea to run
this through the VHS player oh that was
such a good touch and it makes a huge
difference it's so 80s you Ru my
childhood I it Matt I really appreciate
you making this because now my kids know
not to shrink and drive did this scratch
your 80s Grindhouse itch yes I think
absolutely it did for this
[Music]
month we did it we made another rated R
Trailer but this isn't the first and
it's not the last um I actually directed
another one of these it's Spider-Man
rated R uh you can check that on the
links what is the state of links right
now are they still on the screen or are
they down what's going on with links
these days